it was only a matter of time before the
found footage genre brought us a family
film then waiting for this one guys all
those horror movies I've been wanting a
PG rated one earth to echo is a
found-footage tale about three young
boys who are faced with their entire
neighborhood being demolished on the
night before they have to move they
decide to go out on this adventure on
their bicycles they bring their cameras
one of them is trying to make a short
film about all this stuff their phones
are acting strange seems to create like
some kind of mapping system that leads
them somewhere where they find this
little thing that begins leading them
all over the place all night on their
bicycles that starts an adventure that
they'll never forget
sometimes found footage can be used
interestingly it can be used in a way
that actually boosts the material it
makes you feel like there is more
realism then there are times where it
just feels like it's a gimmick where
it's used to mask poor storytelling
where they don't really have the budget
they want to make the story they want to
make so they go the found-footage route
because that's so much more cheaper and
earth to echo started out pretty good I
was very surprised the way the film
began because I was actually invested in
these three kids that was one of the
best parts of this movie and the best
strength of this movie was the
relationship between these three kids
felt very real they really did feel like
friends and it kind of reminded me of my
childhood a little bit - the sci-fi
stuff they're just out at night with a
video camera trying to make movies and I
found that very very appealing because
my friends and I did that all the time
when I was a kid so I actually really
got into the first act of this movie
then they meet this little guy this guy
they call echo and the movie turns into
a gigantic copy off of ET and super 8
but the film started out in a way that
was not like ET and I was like okay this
is cool but then it literally turns into
a scene for scene ripoff of the exact
plot points of ET literally everything
from meeting a girl a chase and a van
bicycle chases government people who are
after them everything was just it was
exactly like ET and when you eventually
realize what this thing is doing I was
like that's super 8 what started as a
different and appealing look at
friendship turned into a ripoff of some
other movies that were good
one of the biggest problems I did have
this movie is that the success of this
film hinges on the emotional bond that
is made between these three boys and
this little thing you're supposed to
really feel that in this movie you don't
in fact you don't really even see the
little guy that much and so you didn't
really feel much of a connection there
and so when certain decisions are made
towards the end of the movie from the
main young boy of the film the main
character really are the film decides
he's gonna do something that sort of
puts a lot of lives in jeopardy in that
moment and I didn't actually understand
where that came from
you're more discerning audience member
may pay attention to the fact that this
kid took hundreds of lives into his hand
in one moment without any real thought
and it was sort of just glossed over
that being said though the kids in this
movie are great especially this kid who
portrays the character named munch he
was fantastic in this movie the
friendship felt very real their
performances were very entertaining
these kids did a great job and I'm very
interested in seeing what else they do
because they have a future the story of
this film just feels like a ripoff of ET
and certain things that happen in the
end really questioned the morality of
the movie because you didn't really feel
the emotional bond between this thing
and the kid that was needed to make this
decision the kid makes work I'm gonna
give earth to echo a see it started out
strong it looked interesting it looked a
little bit different but then it just
became a giant copy and the emotional
bond just wasn't there
now guys a lot of you been asking where
I get my t-shirts because I like I mean
a lot like I get comments I get emails I
get tweets all the time like where do
you get your awesome t-shirts first off
thanks for thinking they're awesome
second jack-of-all-trades clothing
dot-com that's where I got this shirt
that I'm wearing quite a bit of the
super hair shirts that I wear the
Captain America one the Batman one a lot
of you guys asked me and that's why I'm
addressing this jack-of-all-trades
clothing comm check them out they got a
lot of great comic book stuff they're a
really cool website so if you guys see
earth to echo let me know what you
thought of it below and as always thank
you so much for watching guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck man eyes
[Music]